hey pills yo
pretty sweet recent video on depression
and sadness and unhappiness it wasn't
only on that
no no i know i know it was good but you
know what kind of grinds my gears these
days
with all the theory folk what's that
victor
it's you know i feel like there's just
so much emphasis right now
about unhappiness the dooming i feel
like dooming is ubiquitous everywhere
and you know everyone wants to talk
about how unhappy everyone is
think pieces written about unhappiness
and mental health which obviously i'm
not against that's a good thing
but what about happiness uh what is it
like to be happiness i feel like i'd
like a think piece
about somebody you know confessing about
how happy they are or is that
i feel like being happy right now is out
it's kind of it's so out that it's
almost transgressive to be happy
you can't be happy if you're happy right
you can't trust happy people
as pharaoh williams said do you hear
that story about that
woman singing because i'm happy
yeah singing in the car and then the
recording just ends with
woman was killed thursday morning while
posting selfies and driving
her last words to her friends were the
happy song makes me happy
i think that describes happiness pretty
well
[Music]
well i do want to say that i've only
ever encountered
one person who claims to be relatively
content in
all of pop culture uh and that was keith
richards
uh and when he was asked how it is that
he's managed to live a long life
considering all his hedonistic habits
his exact response was
most people don't [ __ ] know how to
use drugs properly
you have to balance everything out every
single day a little bit of uppers a
little bit of downers
but if you get the formula just right
that's the scientific
way to go about achieving happiness
maybe let me actually
try something out here i i you know we
recently had a little bit of
a twitter debate back and forth about
kind of an unrelated topic but i think
it's related a little bit
because i wonder if a standpoint of like
being
you know critical theory has this
tendency to undermine things we a long
time ago we read a
paper from litur about this right if you
remember episode one
episode one yeah and i feel like there's
a parallel in like dooming
and like i feel like critical theory or
critical approaches that are undermining
other theories
are very consistent and and
uh fit well with this the ubiquitousness
it was a big news event okay
wait we have to restart the conversation
now
eric's not eric's not even here hey eric
i'm listening
[Laughter]
oh god that's funny speaking of drug use
i'm really hungry i just ordered pizza
i didn't eat lunch i didn't think i'd be
doing this
yeah yeah i know you forgot i'm not
happy
okay welcome to 31 where we're very much
not happy the laughter is the mask
believe the mask
anyway um we're here sort of as a
co-release with my most recent video
which was
more about depression
and victor takes issue with it victor
thinks that uh being happy should be
cool again make happy
cool again i think it's too it's a
little it's very cool to be a doomer
right now
i think i don't know does anyone
disagree with me it's hard
not to be and that makes it like totally
we have a whole
everybody wants to be a doomer and cool
so you know the really cool thing is to
be happy
just [ __ ] show up every day with a
smile on your goddamn face
and talk about why it is that pop music
makes you
you know just feel great there's a
there's a term for
for what we do every morning it's called
doom scrolling when you just mainline a
bunch of bad news
and i think that's what everybody's
doing how can you not be uh
a doomer yeah and i think it's
operating under the assumption that uh
discontentedness is a choice
well do you have any of you ever read
ovid's metamorphosis there's a joke in
that that i think it's kind of
jermaine here
well i have but i don't remember that i
don't know if i've read the story you're
talking 800 pages long yeah
it's long anyway so um i can't remember
who it is one of the gods
asked you know who gets more out of sex
uh
men and women and god says men get more
out of sex than women do
and then they're asked well why that
doesn't seem fair and it's like well
men enjoy sex ten times more than women
because
men expect ten times less of it than
they do and i think that
that has some relevance when it comes to
happiness right a lot of the people i
know who are particularly happy
tend to have low expectations when it
comes to a lot of things
right they don't go in thinking this has
all got to be
100 great you know they get their
mcdonald's and it's warm
and the french fries are relatively
crispy and they're like this is a
[ __ ] good day
whereas a lot of people i know
particularly academics intellectuals and
artists
think that life needs to be a glorious
wonderful experiment that's going to
have epic highs
and consequently when most of life is
too mundane they get really disappointed
and experience
dramatic lows usually a lot more
dramatic lows than the epic highs
so presumably matt's in the first camp
there oh no i get discontented at
everything i always expect things to be
like
a hundred and fifty percent okay do you
oh yeah i thought you were calling me
out i felt called out
no no no that's my paranoia tendencies
coming out but
the problem with these mcdonald's fries
that you bring up is perfect
is that they're so good but only like
the first
10 fries are good i wonder if eric is
sitting there being like oh yeah
[ __ ] fries they progressively turn
into
worse and worse until like the end of
the box you might as well just throw it
out
i get the same thing with potato chips
well i'm curious like so what would you
guys say your default
state of mind is you know like like
veering towards like
more that the the latter or the former
of matt's description
well i'm a hundred percent the latter
but you've said before once
on on this podcast victor that you don't
get depressed
that's true i will confess that i i'm a
happy person
like by default i'm contented see that
sounds like also
like depression is thought of as a
mental disorder that also sounds like a
mental disorder
not in a bad way it's just like it's not
what everybody else is like
yeah that's true i mean it's true like
that's that's maybe what i was kind of
thinking about is i feel like there's a
lot of uh
you know modernity is is leading to i
mean i don't know who to blame for this
the growth in the phenomenon of what
seems like dooming and
unhappiness but i really identify with
exactly what um matt matt was saying
that you know i i would say that i have
pretty low expectations
uh for things like you know i assume
people are going to disappoint me
i assume and like you know i mean
i feel like i'm good at appreciating i
don't know but like what would you say
are moments that like how can you guys
identify like moments when you do feel
like you're getting the satisfaction or
or like i don't know i mean happiness is
such a vague term anyway right it's like
yeah before we get there can we
say like depression it has a clinical
definition of course um and it's not
necessarily opposed to happiness either
yeah i agree i think uh if you've if
you've seen the video i
opposed it to like a sense of vitality
it can be exhaustion it could be sadness
so it's not necessarily just uh
happy versus depressed because i'm not
i'm not
personally depressed but i think i of
dispositions
of the four dispositions um i'm a
melancholic
so depressive might be better
description than
depressed right i think that actually
um kierkegaard captured it best uh and
um highlight the difference by pointing
to two 90s all rock bands
okay is one of them nirvana
yeah one of them is going to be yeah
author of joy division right
uh but you know unhappy people tend to
be
disappointed in the circumstances
surrounding them uh but the thing is
that there's a kind of fix to that right
which is if you change the circumstances
then the root of their own happiness is
gone and so things will be better
right and that's the kind of attitude
you see with the smashing pumpkins right
where billy corgan is just disappointed
in the world around him
if he fixes things uh it'll be okay uh
the difference between that and
depression or
despair right is for somebody who's
really depressed or really despairing
the biggest central problem in their
life is themselves right this chronic
feeling of disappointment in who they
are
and the problem with that is there's no
fix to it right you're always going to
be you
unless you decide to end that in which
case you know you can put a stop to it
uh you're going to follow yourself
around wherever you go and so you'll
always be
in the muck of your problems because
you'll carry them around with you
wherever you happen to go right and
that's exactly you know how kirk cobain
felt right in
a lot of his music right uh you think
about something like all apologies right
really what he's apologizing for
is being himself melancholic is the
depressed one is which one is happiness
is that
sanguine sanguine has like a
pejorative quality to it though on the
four humors scale right there's
there's sanguine choleric melancholic
and uh what's the fourth one phlegmatic
oh phlegmatic that's the fourth one what
does that what does that even mean
you have too much too much phlegm
there's there's
sanguine happy cleric anger
what is sanguine like uh sanguine means
blood right
it's too much blood yeah you're bursting
at the seams with blood
is it lustful and violent i think yeah
it's like something or something
overactive hyper maybe something like
that my little graph
says that's for gemini's libras and
aquarius
i posted it to my instagram that's where
the real root of happiness and
unhappiness comes it's all set by the
stars
it's all connected the stars my fluids
my moods yeah i mean i also kind of want
to make a distinction too between
you know because i think happiness
itself is such an ambiguous
category that i feel like encompasses
like a lot of different
states of being because i think you know
i'm sure all of you guys
know this feeling um when you're like
working towards something that you
really like feel passionate about but
but like a part of that process is
you're you're sort of suffering because
you have to like put a lot of effort
into it
but you also feel like most alive and
most like meaningful with that work that
you're doing that you have to overcome
which you know you can't be in that
state all the time and then there's
maybe
what i feel like my default is when i'm
like not doing that which is not like
this
you know state of bliss like i don't
think happiness is like oh like i'm
feeling blissful all the time it's just
like
a base level of contentment of like you
know not being
like uh not being predisposed towards
like depression or self-loathing or like
anger like whatever
those different kinds of things are it's
just like a bass level but it's not like
this kind of pleasurable eruption right
i think
uh so like i don't know there's like
that bass line but then there's also
those moments of overcoming something
which i think nietzsche is actually very
good at
describing vividly right like putting
your soul into a work and overcoming
something and like the adversity which
is both
painful uh it can be painful anyway but
it's also uh
where you feel like the most meaningful
states i think
those creative kind of overcomings yeah
there's a couple different ways
people talk about happiness but one of
them is not
well one of them is just kind of an
absence of negative affect
that's sort of that's sort of how health
is
sometimes defined as just like an
absence of negative
yeah but uh when but happiness should be
like a positive state
right but then there's two other ways
that we've mentioned
today already is that happiness has
something to do with balance
happiness has something to do with like
having order in your life
it's like when if you watch dexter
that's always his thing is like
compartmentalizing and keeping things
apart and that's how he finds happiness
as things stay
separate from one another and he stays
in control
and then the other kind way is is the
highs and the lows right happiness
requires contrast it requires lows to be
seen against which kind of contradicts
the idea of balance really because if
there's highs and lows then you're not
really there's not order there maybe
there is
that's interesting i mean it makes me
think of like greek definitions of
happiness right because i think the
greek ancient greek def
in ancient greek philosophy it's all
about like the harmony of your soul
right like
aristotelian you have the virtues in in
correct order right you're not
there's like for those who don't know
right like aristotle's ethics are all
about
finding the mean between an excess and a
defect of
of something so i don't know being like
like generosity is a virtue
uh which is in between like being stingy
and then being um
overly generous and like the ideas all
these different virtues you have to find
that balance and that harmony
in between them i do like that better
sorry as i say i think that simone
bolvar is right in a hegelian vein
uh and saying that the deepest kind of
happiness we can get because there's a
lot of different kinds of happiness that
we can have
right i think a kind of immediate
visceral pleasure from
cracking a cold beer you know if that
beer happens to be
it might even be a tremendous sense of
personal gratification and pleasure
i'm bleeping that out until they decide
to sponsor us you should reach out
points out and i think this is really
thought relevant is if you actually
think about the happiest moments of your
life
and you ponder how many of them you were
alone for you'd probably come up with an
extremely short list
right uh whereas a lot of times the
worst periods in our life uh
immediately either immediately follow
periods uh where we are alone
uh or are when we are alone or at least
when we feel alone
right uh and one of the things that you
point out is this demonstrates to us how
it is that we need to understand
our moods intersubjectively right here's
my
all branch uh to the critics of liberal
atomism from a couple weeks ago right
you reminded me of another version of
happiness and it's in the little things
that's the other one right
people always talk about finding
happiness in the little things
often like as part of some kind of
hard-headed pragmatic rant about life
sucking and you never getting that
quarterback position or something
buy a [ __ ] helmet smoke a cigarette
find happiness in the little things
orgasms chocolate i do think that's good
advice though
i mean i usually criticize jordan
peterson but there was some truth to
this idea that you know if you find
gratitude for the small pleasures that
you have in life and don't feel guilty
about them
that can help you get through things day
by day right
i think this can even have profound
significance so i was reading a memoir
about a soldier
who was looking at his counterpart
across the trenches
uh smoking a cigarette and he felt a
profound moment of empathy with him
because he was also a smoker
and he decided not to shoot him uh
because he thought it was
rude uh to shoot somebody who was
enjoying a cigarette right
but it's this kind of profoundly
intersubjective moment uh where the
little things
actually brought him back uh to a sense
of their shared humanity right and this
is
kind of what the beauvoir is getting at
where she says if you think about a lot
of the ways that love
or regalian recognition if you want to
use it in the most profound sense
uh is misunderstood is that we see
love as somebody caring for us
um unconditionally right
and she says in its most sincere form
that can be
really the source of a lot of our
happiness because we feel like there's
someone else
who understands who we are and who
believes uh that that's something that's
intrinsically important
right and it's hard to get a much more
powerful feeling gratification than that
she says of course though that the
downside to this is that uh
most of the sadness that we find in life
come from warped iterations uh of this
desire for love
right uh and she says if you think about
why it is that people end up in unhappy
relationships whether under patriarchy
or otherwise
uh is a lot of times what we interpret
love as being is instead just
demanding that someone do what we want
right
i'll provide us with a sense of
affirmation whether they want to
or not right uh and she says if you
think about it that's not love right
what that is is actually
compelling someone uh to do something
that they don't want to do
uh in which case you're never gonna get
the recognition that you really crave uh
or in
circumstances where we feel really
self-conscious relative to other people
kind of demanding that they give us
something um in order to make us feel
better for about ourselves
that they're not in a position to give
all right so i've been writing this
down and i think any time you say
happiness generally comes from
x happiness generally comes from y or
it's negated by x or y
a lot of this comes down to disposition
and i mean myself i would turn to
psychoanal
psychoanalysis to try to figure out
what's my disposition versus what
someone else's disposition is but
as we've been talking i wrote down a few
of these just kill your father it
doesn't matter
i mean you say that as a joke but it's
it's very
clear that one of the sources of negated
happiness
comes from law and i don't mean like
the the government's law i mean like the
law of
of the father like yes but we have
victor mentioned earlier happiness from
accomplishment or like
the struggle overcoming something
accomplishing something
i think that one accompanies the flip
side of a previous episode we did on
burnout
because one one accomplishment that you
strive for
and you finish feels good
uh it feels pleasurable but when there's
like a mountain of
of just tasks and not enough
recognition which is what simone de
beauvoir was talking about
then then it becomes unhappiness well it
also has to be self-given right because
the problem in the burnout society right
was that
the world is pushing all this like
achievement subjectivity on to us
right so i think really the kind of
achievement that i'm thinking of right
are those things where it really feels
like you've given yourself the
the um and maybe it's hard to
disentangle those two things um right
like between
what uh what's actually like self-given
self-actualized versus um
alienated it's almost impossible to be
distant it's almost impossible i suppose
if you want to be a strict kind of
psychoanalytic uh theorist about it to
disentangle between what was actually
given to you and what is like
the other's desire or whatever well even
even
what you're describing is something
non-alienated something that you
undertake
yourself even if it's even if it's to
appease you know some fiction in your
head but still
usually that produces some some sort of
happiness
then then there's sorry i'm gonna finish
my list we have negated from the outside
so then it's an environmental sort of
depression
which we've talked about before um
happiness from balance this is when i
think it's really foreign
to moderns today yeah i don't i don't
think we really consider that but i'm
glad you brought it up
the greek sensibility it's good i think
it's important i'm glad you're bringing
it up again because i think that that is
a
a real contrast um i think that this is
one
way where i will be like a strong critic
of like liberal individualism i think
that it's true that our
our modern capitalist liberal society
in its over emphasis on kind of uh
individual freedom
doesn't you know it's it's a bit it's a
bit awkward or it feels a bit strange to
be like yeah you need to have these
things balanced
to be happy as opposed to or like
talking about concrete things
uh that you could be doing to harmonize
your life because it just
kind of goes against this idea that well
you just need to find yourself and be
whoever you're going to be and it's like
up to you right
there's nothing there's nothing concrete
described that shouldn't even be
like a sub-argument in the balance
section capitalism
and happiness gets its own [ __ ]
section of this of this episode
because that's what's [ __ ] us all up
who's happy what is what is happiness
under capitalism what is it done to it
yeah i think that like what what pill
said earlier on i think is really
important right and we can interpret
this from a freudian standpoint
as kind of an excessively uh stringent
super ego but i'll try to use less
terminologically over determined uh
words right because if you think about
why it is that a lot of people are
unhappy right it kind of relates back to
what i was saying before right this
sense of depression you get
uh when you feel that it's not just that
you don't have what you want is that you
are not good enough and you cannot be
good enough and you never will be good
enough because you're you and that's
something that's polluted and bad
right matt is a catholic by the way in
case anyone was wondering
yeah it is and so i can speak to this
from experience right you know uh
because you can have this
sensibility uh that sometimes can impose
upon itself upon you that
all your failures and all the bad things
that happened to you ultimately had
their seat in you
uh that it relates back to your personal
failings
and that consequently the best thing
that could possibly happen for you is
just
to not be yourself any longer right and
i do think that this
comes from in the excessive imposition
of all those little voices you were
talking about that freud called the
superego
uh just telling you that you're failing
it's your fault
and there's nothing that can be done
about it because
that's just who you are and it's what's
bound to happen right
and i think part of happiness in the
sense that you're talking about
is finding someone who helps take that
away for a little while and the way that
simone de balvar
was talking about but provide providing
you with a sense of
satisfaction and contentment with the
person you are by by offering
recognition
yeah i never finished my list from
earlier okay go ahead
no recognition was the last one so i i
i'm glad to be interrupted because each
of them has its own relevant points
but isn't it crazy how how does
catholicism just
[ __ ] up people so bad for the rest of
their lives
it has a it has a unique the hand that
rocks the cradle
it has a unique ability to do that could
you elaborate on on on why you say that
as a total like non-catholic and
particular it can recognize just
people who are raised catholic just by
the amount of guilt that they feel as
as 30 year old adults still to this day
really it's so true isn't it
that's funny yeah i mean freud used to
have a used to say that the only people
who are immune to psychoanalysis
were irish catholics right and the
reason was just it went
so deep that there was no getting to it
right it's just like
we need [ __ ] you know years and years
to excavate all the layers of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's been repressed here speaking
of colonialism
but what i heard you saying that it's
it's making me think of um
like you know it's interesting how you
wanna how you wanna locate
um the source in other people which i
think there's a lot of truth to that but
i guess
what i think is like the important part
is like you're absolutely right that you
can like having someone else who loves
you and who you love and you feel like
that reciprocal
connection with could be an important
way of doing that but i guess like the
key point kind of like the functional
point is that you're going to stop
believing like taking so seriously those
voices in your head and it's like
whether it's a person who helps you do
that or something else helps you i agree
that
like there's a there's another upshot to
having reciprocal engagement with other
people
but really what we're looking for is to
eliminate or not take that voice in our
head so seriously right that like
can cause sort of like debilitating
you know shame and debilitating judgment
self-judgment and self-loathing
and it's you know that's the mechanism
right and so but i agree that uh other
people can be
a a way of dealing with it the
psychoanalytic
term for that is the consistency of the
big other
trying to break it down yeah but i think
it also just has a kind of common sense
quality to it right i mean
and this relates back to cobit right if
i think back at the best
moments of my life right uh almost none
of them
were by myself right uh there was maybe
that one moment where i finished the
starcraft one campaign for the first
time and i smoked a big joint so
that that was kind of sublime in its own
way but that was that was only a big
joint
right like the 90s buddy yeah exactly
right but you know
the point being and this was in the
early 2000s there but like
everything else you don't involve other
people in some way shape or form
sometimes one person
um oftentimes many people you know what
i mean and i've been reflecting on this
more during covenant which is maybe why
this dubovarian notion attracts me
because in a certain sense you know we
might be able to have our material needs
cared for by you know the state or
um because you have a job or whatever it
happens to be but a lot of people i know
of speak about being very depressed in
part because they miss that kind of
connection
right and i'm hoping one of the lessons
that we take from this whole crisis
is precisely how dependent our sense of
personal
gratification and happiness is uh on
those around us i don't know maybe
then take people less for granted who
knows you know that's that
i yeah i don't disagree with any of that
for sure that seems right i'm also
you know thinking about um actually my
girlfriend and i have been reading this
book uh
uh at the existentialist cafe uh it's
like a sarah bakewell it's like nice
it's nice to revisit existentialism a
little bit and one of the things that
came up in that book
was like the connection between greek
philosophy and existentialism as both
being sort of like philosophies of
self-betterment
in a way like the um so and i think it's
kind of
notable that existentialism is kind of
out of vogue now i think when you look
at the history of sort of 20th century
philosophy you see
um existentialism emerge with jean-paul
sarat heidegger and all these others
right and the emphasis is on freedom
but and then the connection back to
greek philosophy is specifically that
came up in the part of the book i'm
thinking of it's like to stoicism which
i think uh and there's some interesting
contemporary philosophers right now who
do work on stoicism
and a lot of [ __ ] ones also yeah there
are a lot of shows
there's something interesting a very
[ __ ] comeback but if you sort of no but
i think there's some interest i think
there's when it comes to like
self-betterment and like happiness i
think there's something
worthwhile in stoicism because like one
of the points that they make is
you know like yes we have um we can't
really choose
like how our initial like what other
people do what outside forces do to us
but we do have some power over how we
decide to react to things right and like
most of the damage
that's done to our self-esteem when
other people is usually
um when we keep thinking about how bad
that was or like oh how embarrassing
that was it's like the
the self you know perpetuating and i
think existentialism also
you know has that big emphasis i mean i
remember start would always talk about
it doesn't matter how
bad things are you could be in a nazi
prison but you still have a choice
to either like like you know shake the
chains and scream or
uh or just like sit there i in in in a
docile manner and
i and i wonder and i think that what's
interesting about the transition
of philosophy from existentialism to
kind of like post-structuralism
post-modernism is
a transition towards kind of almost
turning
our back completely on freedom right
it's everything is about the structure
you know and like freedom ever like
there's one guy robert solomon an
existentialist that i really that i
really
like i used to i listened to his
lectures when i was a teenager about
existentialism and i remember he said
you know i really like a lot of these
new uh post-structuralist philosophers
but
i feel like it's it's opening up a whole
new world of excuses
in a certain sense for you know not not
like
and kind of totally covering over that
freedom and it's worth mentioning that
the name of those lectures was called no
excuses existentialism so it was like
all about
really emphasizing the freedom and i
think it's just interesting how now
the discourse of critical philosophy
critical theory is
such a strong emphasis on you know the
structures of society and how much
weight they impose on us
and but then like freedom is gone in a
way
well it's interesting that you bring up
existential freedom and stoicism in
relation to
happiness because when i think of
happiness
and i just look at the word and i think
about the word itself
it tends to mean something more
connected to chance
right when we say that happy chance a
happy coincidence
or unhappy chance when something bad
happens
and stoicism and existentialism are both
very much about freedom from within
happiness from within
you know holding yourself away from the
vicissitudes of life and being happy no
matter what happens or at least
you know when you're taught what
existential freedom is it's like you're
free
in any situation no matter what whether
you're a slave or in any kind of
situation because you can always just
kill yourself or take yourself
out of that situation in some kind of
radical way and that's
kind of that existential freedom which
is a little bit i don't know
but then today and when i said
capitalism and happiness were very much
in the chance realm
it's all about fortuna it's all about
making big bucks that's what makes you
happy money buys happiness
and you have to be one of the lucky ones
who gets born into wealth
or else you're one of the unlucky
unhappy 90 percent
who just struggle every day to put food
on the table
for tuna yes but machiavelli always said
that for tuna you have to take you have
to grab it and and
seize it when it a woman and you have
comes
beat her into submission is that what he
said about that i did say that actually
and what did uh say about nature nature
is a woman and we have to torture her to
get her secrets
out yes yes the the sexism is
problematic but that's beside the point
there's a huge sexist element because
what is happiness associated with it's
associated with smiling we
we look at unhappy people as ungrateful
that's always the right wing line right
is that they're ungrateful you know
smile babe
and there's a huge sexist element to
happiness in our society too
that's interesting yeah and if you think
of
happiness as balance and our society
seems out of balance in so many ways how
can it produce happy subjects
how can i be happy when there's such
wealth disparity in the world for
example
yeah this is why it says that maybe the
whole notion of merit
uh needs to be not get thrown away uh
but at least seriously questioned right
because it's not just that society is
unfair and that generates a lot of
happiness he that absolutely does
and it's just that this whole notion
that we have to have a competition for
winners and losers
uh that produces winners and losers
generates a tremendous amount of
unhappiness i just want to say something
that speaks to like what victor was
saying earlier about existentialism
though and actually kind of
agrees with you in a certain way uh
because i think eric is right that the
problem with a lot of this be grateful
don't show resentment uh recognize your
freedom rhetoric is it can very easily
be appropriated for
highly reactionary causes and has yeah
right absolutely
i do think though that there is a
certain amount of truth uh and wendy
brown also points to this out in our own
uh reflections on nietzsche
right to the contention that if you
start to define yourself exclusively by
all the things that oppress depressed uh
and seem to get in your way uh then
you're very quickly going to
just be defined uh by everything that's
wrong in the world around you
right uh and you don't want to allow
that to happen because if anything
that allows the forces of oppression to
win right um
now what the solution to that is i'm not
sure right
uh but i think we can all imagine people
who are like this in fact i know some of
them right
yeah i know a lot of those yeah
everything is wrong with the world
everything's bad
uh they can't do anything about it uh so
why even try right well that's i mean
you kind of took the words out of my
mouth because that was exactly the point
i wanted to make because i did want to
be really clear here that i'm not like
defending some naive
like individuals like like i'm
definitely not but but i guess you know
actually i mean it kind of connects to
the balance point i just feel like right
now there's just such an emphasis such a
strong emphasis on like exactly like the
wendy brown point on everything we're
being we're a victim of everything
around us which there's a truth to it
but i think like thinking of ourselves
like that also has a potentially
deleterious effect on
on our on ourselves yeah i mean i could
think that the times in my life i was
most unhappy and i felt most hard done
by
right um sometimes i could get outraged
by it and kind of strike back right
but it was usually a point where i felt
there's really just nothing i could do
right um i wasn't going to be able to
overcome the problems that i was faced
with
so there was really no point in trying
so i should just give up because the
whole situation is just too shitty
right yeah and i mean and yeah so well i
just want to
also like defend because i think also
sart gets
um i think he gets a bit strawman
sometimes because i like i do think he
like a big aspect is you know he never
said that we have like
radical freedom to do whatever he's like
the situ you can't control the situation
that you're in
like capitalism is part of the situation
right like
the the the ideology you know like our
psychology all of that is part of our
situation
but he still very much wants to defend
that there's like a core
uh that is still ours for the taking
that we can we can do something with it
i want a question that cora set because
i think when you're defining it
in this other or lack of recognition
versus recognition
sense of like i'm not getting the thing
from the world that i need
that sounds a little bit alien to what i
describe as
probably more like dread which is an
unhappiness
just from existing i
all right well i don't i don't want to
get too anecdotal here but
uh as a more introverted person
when when whether or not i'm getting
recognition from other people there's
also a sense of
a disposition that i have towards the
world
that's not that and it's not precisely
that the world's
hostile but more like the whole thing is
profoundly
indifferent like the world itself
is on the verge of of collapse like it's
held together by this little bit of
will and in the future it's already
collapsed that's the the destiny of the
world and the universe is to be nothing
but for now there's some little bit of
remaining force holding it together
we're not free we can't hold it together
and this fleeting temporality
paradoxically on the other hand is what
makes it special but i don't
i don't draw my sense of of uh
unhappiness from saying capitalism's bad
more than that like subtle feeling
of dread that kind of underlies
experience it's like
yeah well it's it's funny because
literally everything you said i agree
with like i think that everything that
you said is true but i just
do not feel that i don't know i don't
like it doesn't i've
some like i would say i would say the
only time i really like feel that
occasionally is like
if i have a hard time sleeping or
something sometimes i'll like meditate
on my own mortality and how i'm gonna
like you know
one day i'm just gonna be nothing like
like non-existent and it's like
that gives me like a little moment of
like a pit in my stomach a little bit of
dread but overall
i just feel privileged to be alive and
to get to experience at all uh
i'm just happy about that like that just
i'm just so like
i wish that i had that escape because
that first feeling is what kind of
dominates any quiet moment
i think that's actually really important
though victor and like i'll kind of
build upon the star trek point you're
making
uh with reference to a book by eli
wizard called knight right
uh so eli wazell um was a romanian jew
who ended up
uh being taken to auschwitz his whole
family was killed uh
and then they were marched uh back to
germany uh where almost everyone else in
the camp ended up perishing right
uh and the book is amongst other things
a really profound rumination on what it
means to be happy
uh in the face of like these kind of
abyssal situations right
uh and what you kind of notice is that
there really is a kind of star tree and
flavor to some of this
uh because of course these people were
under a system of unbelievable
oppression and it's hard to imagine
a much more oppressive situation right
uh but people could still choose in that
kind of situation
to a certain degree how they were going
to respond to this right whether they
were going to continue to value
their life and other people's life
around them by demonstrating small acts
of kindness to others
right or whether or not they were just
wanting to take this kind of cynical
attitude that nothing mattered including
themselves
the only thing that was important was
kind of eeking out one day
uh at a time right a slippery slope here
well it's a very difficult thing and
this is one other point about knight
right which is that
there's a very thin line uh between
these two positions right
uh but one of the things that wizel
points out is that it's the people who
still kind of felt that something
mattered
uh and that chose to act upon that that
typically did better than the cynics
right because the cynics as soon as uh
you know almost ironically constantly
talk about how something bad was gonna
happen
and then they felt affirmed by that when
the worst did occur
and their whole world collapsed yeah you
keep you keep bringing this
choice and decision and i'm saying what
i'm describing
at least for myself it's not a choice
and it's not a conscious choice
for sure it's a disposition
that minimal happiness coming with it
like
we can't can we get through an episode
on happiness without saying i'm just
happy to be alive or i'm just thankful
for my life and that i can do at all you
know what there's already a word for
that
you know what it is it's called bear
life that's the word for that and it's
not
hacking happiness it's just existing
great i exist in my capitalist society
and i
am thankful for it that's called bear
life it's not just
but i i think it's not flourishing
that's not a positive
description of happiness that's just
like well at least you're not dead
but well i mean i would say that it's
it's i mean
that's not exactly the position i would
hold about it's more a reaction to
that insight that pills was talking
about like that dark insight about like
the nothingness
out there is like it's not so much that
i'm just happy to be alive but in
reaction to that i guess
my feeling is just like sweet and all
that blackness
i got to be a blip of consciousness and
like that i don't know that's like
it's not that's not the only reason i'm
happy obvious that's not like the thing
that sustains my happiness
but that's specific to when i have those
dread insights about like the
nothingness and the blackness of
existence
well i'd also don't want to be
melodramatic and say like i walk around
life like this all the time but
you know when when things make singing
in cosmological terms no i mean when
when i start getting excited about
something then i just know it's like
10 hours away i'm gonna start feeling
that other way pretty quick
but it's it's it's well i wanna yeah so
one thing i want to say though is
you know in agreement with pills and and
um eric is
yeah like i think emphasizing choices is
potentially problematic even though like
i do think that there's something
important about thinking about ourselves
as
and even if it's not true it's like
maybe even a useful fiction
but the other thing it's like worth
considering is like you know there is
probably just a lot of luck like i'm
probably just for some reason
dispositionally
contented and like you know that's not
because of any choices i'm making
right like i'm not i'm not making
choices that like you guys
or whatever aren't making it's just i
just won the lottery for some reason my
parents who knows
like who knows what it is right like
genetic parent like i don't know but
like so
yeah like we have to consider that as
definitely like a real possibility i
want to put it somewhat different way
right
because one of the people that really
inspire me when it comes to a lot of
these things is eric fromm
right uh who also wrote in the context
of nazi germany right and
the way that he relates choice back to
happiness is
in this kind of artful way right where
he says if you think about
who people are right what makes them an
individual is the decisions that they
make
right and if you're someone who takes
joy in other people then you want them
to be more of who they are which means
that you want them to have the freedom
to make the kind of choices that they're
going to make
right and this is why real love is about
understanding and empathizing with
somebody
uh for who they are rather than who you
want to be since of course if you don't
care for them
unless they're who you want to be you're
taking that kind of choice away from
them right
but one of the things that he says
exemplified nazism
at its core was precisely this terror
at freedom right which in turn leads to
this belief that
the fundamental problem with the world
is that there are too many individuals
making choices that i don't understand
don't like out there
and i need total control over it and one
of the things that from says is that
this is only going to end up in a
nihilistic kind of attitude that reveres
death because ultimately
death is the ultimate form order can
take
right it's a world strip to freedom
individuality and the possibility for
ever being disappointed
right uh which is why it says eventually
fascism is going to end with sending
people to death camps
even though on the surface it seems like
being about uh
you know nationalism and all this kind
of stuff and i really think that there's
some truth to that right which is
why when wizal says when you're in these
kind of circumstances
and you make a choice to be a good
person in a very limited way that you
can
uh to another person uh it's reflective
of a very important point about
happiness which is that happiness comes
from
acknowledging the other and then to
yourself as someone who matters
right uh as who they are not as what you
want them to be
yeah but what if it's not about the
other what if the universe
is the other and the universe is a
horrible dark god
zanadu is out there and just oh no
what's his name cthulhu i mean
hitler comes along just like any other
government really doesn't
when they're tapping into i don't know
if you can call it unhappiness or some
kind of deep sadness and offering a
scapegoat
offering a way out of some terrible
situation how about
disc intense yeah the discontents
of society if the if if that
situation gets out of hand then a little
demagoguery is going to go a long way
and you're going to be able to convince
people either to sign some kind of new
deal
or to help establish some kind of
concentration camps and it's it's i
guess
it makes the the psychoanalytic lesson
that you learn from watching something
like century of the self is that is that
unhappiness makes people very pliable
and psychoanalysis in concert with
things like
advertising and even just all kinds of
like media and political messaging
propaganda
and public relations making people
unhappy makes them pliable
that's a good variant it's dangerous
when it gets out of hand yeah
like we're seeing it now even a lot of
like a lot of people blame the rise of
the right and trump ism and stuff on
people being
you know essentially unhappy for lack of
more words but yeah it's we should be
skeptical
of the happiness being offered to us all
the time that's if
critical theory is about questioning
everything as adorno says
then we should question and what kinds
of happiness are we closer to in our
day-to-day lives than the
[ __ ] we see in commercials the stuff
were promised
by the sort of market that we live in
the lifestyles
that are modeled for us and the the ways
were
i guess what they used to think of as
the ways were programmed to consume
through attaching products to images
and lifestyles and effects and affects
like happiness or things like that like
we
as critical theorists or as doing a
critical theory podcast
a skepticism towards happiness in a way
it
it's hard to be happy with that because
is it the authentic thing or is it
liquid happiness is it drug happening is
it happy pills
i mean you speak for yourself as soon as
i make as soon as i make 150 grand and
get my cocaine and my [ __ ]
lamborghini it's all gonna be
[ __ ] uphill from there baby yeah or
you get your swag and you're happy there
too money
money can't buy me love but it can sure
make me [ __ ] happy
well i just want to say to anyone out
there who
who faces the abyss and it stares at you
and you feel hollow inside
the honestly the reason that i do
read like enjoy talk about philosophy
is because it's the only thing that kind
of answers
that and uh specifically phenomenology
at least for me
paying attention to how you pay
attention so
i i mean matt you keep bringing up like
other and other people
and like for me i mean i i'm sure that's
true for you because you're an extrovert
an
extremely social person but for me
it's kind of uh more reminding myself
that i'm in the world that the world is
uh
appearing to me and the fact that it's
appearing to me in time
that it's not appearing elsewhere that i
can have awareness of the fact that it
appears to me
even paying attention to that in kind of
a form
of godless meditation
that kind of brings me back to oh yeah
i'm in a body
okay like i'm not in the dread i don't
have to think about the creeping
fungal approach of doom uh
and yeah that like phenomenology is
formed
as a form of meditation in my mind
specifically merli ponte
the flesh anyone uh been on my patreon
they know that
how much i like that book well i'm going
to respond to that by saying that
i would actually kind of reorient a
little bit by saying
i'm actually a very introverted person a
lot of ways right but
this and this is one of the reasons i
actually found phenomenology and in
particular heidegger extremely
entrancing when i was younger precisely
because
there is this kind of capacity that you
find in this work to find meaning in
your individuated projects
that orient you toward authenticity and
self-creation
right but what i've kind of experienced
by trying to
figure out how to live that in practice
is that i think hegel was actually more
right than these people right that
introspection on the conditions of your
own understanding and the conditions for
your own possibilities
will never bring you any kind of real
gratification right
that can only come from finding meaning
in something that's external to yourself
that seems more important than you and
what it is that you're doing
uh and i think some people find that in
god and that's fine
um as from a secular standpoint i think
we have to find that in other people
or if you want you know other sentient
beings uh to kind of
see it a point to eric when it comes to
things like uh you know
animals and uh other conscious entities
so we're kind of admitting that we all
just use philosophy for cope
i guess oh [ __ ] yeah i mean what did
nietzsche said right now every
philosopher creates a philosophy that
deals with his or her problems right
it's all kind of psychotherapy yeah
it's a biography it's a biography of
yourself uh yeah it's funny you know
i kind of want to also respond to to
matt because you know i i actually
i mean i do identify with the importance
of other people but at the same time
like my own experience and i don't know
if this is gonna like sound
dickish or something but like i would
say that like the only times i'm like
unhappy are because of other people
like like like i would say that like
like you know i very much
identify with starts you know but like
point held as other people like like i
feel like um
i just don't uh i like when i'm alone
i'm i'm always like pretty much at a
base level of contentment
um and like can entertain myself or i
don't know like what i don't i feel like
i don't really get bored
that much and the end like but yeah it's
funny like obviously other people like
end up enriching they almost
act as a platform for when i'm by myself
i can feel better because i like
get enriched by being around other
people but um
but yeah i don't i actually and i pl and
i have for the record i have plenty of
very good memories
by myself i was gonna say that too i was
like i don't want to be the only one to
say
yeah no no i i have fun that's fair i
mean i'm just thinking for my own
experiences
and reflections right i mean if you
experience differently that's fine yeah
but i do want to say i think that
beauvoir and hegel and prom all
acknowledge this right which is that
there's a weird situation where other
people
and the kind of externalization of
meaning that we find in them is
simultaneously the source of both our
greatest happiness
and of course our profound
disappointment right uh because other
people
are the only thing that i think that can
give you true contentment but that also
means that they're the only thing that
can really disappoint you
right uh and when it comes to those
little voices and guilt that
people feel that really can make them
depressed right uh a lot of that stems
initially from the sense that
the things that you care about outside
are being let down by you
right you're failing in some ways uh and
that's the quickest route to sort to
thinking to start thinking that you're
just not good enough the problem lies
with you
and there's just no way of resolving it
right
and i think you can also see this best
expression devopar writes really
artfully in this in romantic
relationships right
the best and worst relationships that we
have are typically with our romantic
partner
because she or he is the one that can
provide you with real recognition and
acknowledge who you are
and they're also the person that can
essentially take everything that you are
away
right by forcing you to be someone that
you're not
on the on the along the line of the the
sort of lovecraftian
void and staring into the abyss and sort
of
naming this fundamental negative
i don't know tendency inside of people
there's a whole sort of
aesthetic like subcultures that seem to
find
happiness in sadness finding happiness
in melancholy and you know you think of
like the gothic sensibilities
right of all the way from gothic novels
of the past
to horror movies today to the sort of
gothic movement
and people who enjoy that sort of
aesthetic finding the happiness and the
gross things or the icky things or the
melancholic things
i mean that's like going full
contradiction there now it's not even
like happiness is avoiding suffering
oh no there's happiness but it has to
come with suffering oh now there's
happiness
in suffering suffering is a kind of
happiness or at least the aesthetic
quality of it insofar as it defines
these genres and subcultures
it's there's a happiness even uh what's
uh
nirvana they sing i miss the comfort in
being sad and things like that all the
time it's like
depression is a source of comfort for
people in many ways
yeah well which it makes me think that
happiness is like the wrong word
sometimes
that like yeah you know like it's like
maybe fulfillment would be like a more
uh
apt term to use for some of these
examples you're bringing up
and it's again it's the society that
encourages chasing your dreams and
chasing happiness
that has more suicides than any other
culture right exactly well that's
exactly
my point about like the word happiness
like i don't think that we're aiming i
mean because
because if you equate happiness with
like that kind of capitalist
like you know modern dream then yeah
like i don't i don't think that that's
um that's definitely not what i'm
talking about when i think about uh
happiness or fulfillment or whatever but
um
i want to say also just related to this
that um pills
made a video about david foster wallace
uh i mean he pointed out really
accurately that starting in the 1990s
there was a real industry and a
commodification of sadness
that started to emerge and that very
quickly vulgarized it right
uh you know and he said you know in one
very chilling interview students he did
end up taking his own life
uh that people are now starting to
realize that suicide can be a good
career move
right uh because you can become an icon
you know you can become the next
kirklane or ian curtis or mark fisher
right by having these legions of sad
people line up to
listen and absorb what you're doing uh
because they think it's gonna reveal
some trend some transcendent truth
uh when the sad reality of course is
that a lot of people who end up taking
their own life
feel exactly that they're the last
person that anybody should be listening
to because they're just not good enough
and marfisher also wrote about this very
eloquently in his book on ontology
uh and depression right that the kind of
problem with the commodification
of sadness is that it takes the very
last dignity from depression
uh away from you right uh since now you
can't be sure
that you're not just performing
depression
as some kind of career move right uh if
you're a well-known enough figure
and that's really got to be a crappy
feeling right to know that if i feel sad
it might just be because i'm kind of
projecting this desire to
appear upset to other people uh so that
they'll be attracted to me
and find something profound on what i'm
doing you're bringing up an important
point i think because um
one observation that we might make
between like sort of modern versus
ancient conceptions of happiness right
is like
you know aristotle used that word
eudaimonia to talk about happiness and
it's like
basically meant like beautiful life like
there's like it's like this person is
living
a beautiful life and it's like you know
and i think to some extent the greeks
looked at looked up to people who were
living this beautiful life it's like
that's like much more of a greek value
but nowadays
i feel like the people we look up to
right the figures that we're like look
it's like this heroic person who's
actually miserable like
this heroic artist who's going through
all this suffering like
guilty i mean i i revered a lot of those
people like i [ __ ] like
wore out my nirvana records just like
nobody no nobody
nobody really like looks up cultural
like i would say like culturally right
now
like someone who's living like some
people where you're like man that guy's
got it together like he's
you know he's living a balanced life or
that girl is living like this
beautiful life like that has no currency
i feel like
like today no i think the people that
admire david foster wallace are far
fewer in number than the people that
admired jake paul
but do you think that people actually
think that jake paul is living a
beautiful life like i don't think that's
what they admire about him
it doesn't matter it's the fantasy that
matters i don't even know who jake paul
is i think
is he the boxing one or the other one
he's the boxing one i think
happiness is fantasy i gotta say inject
into your
uh intervention into greeks achilles was
emo as [ __ ]
first sponsor he's beating his breast
and whining and crying and
he's crying until hector will come out
and fight him um
but b i think even the the
valorization of off i think we would
call it this
a kind of a cult of authenticity sort of
fisher
foster wallace kirk cobain they're more
authentic because they actually like
did the deed you know um yeah i think
that i think that might come
more from recognition
almost like the person who has off
themselves
recognizes what you feel right
that's true yeah mark fisher put it
really really
depressingly where he said you become
like in this really sparing way and
can't remember what essay said where is
like
if you become a popular enough person
you start to realize that there are some
people
who want you to commit suicide to prove
to them that you were really sad
right like i'm your fan show me that you
really meant it
right uh because that way i could
continue to revere you and
that's a really [ __ ] perverse thing
to imagine right
i'm not sure if this was just in his
head uh
you know as a result of like having
imbibing this culture but the fact that
somebody could reach that conclusion is
really
telling about the kind of weird
fetishization of sadness uh that victor
was talking about right
i'd just like to point out i think we're
at the point now where we have said
the big s word enough times that
we're gonna probably have to put a
proviso at the beginning of this episode
and so it's going to be like pillpot
episode on happiness
warning we discuss suicide quite often
people are going to look at that and be
like what the [ __ ] is happening on this
hey you were the only one who said the
word now we can't put it on youtube
don't you remember what jesus said jesus
had the swelling thing in his recent
book where he's like
sometimes people take a great
satisfaction out of the fact that they
can commit suicide right um
[ __ ] what did he say is like you know
you sit there and you think oh man i got
a lot of problems in my life i got to
pay my taxes my life is going to leave
me
nope just going to [ __ ] opt out right
well it's funny didn't you
say that um for him uh you know he
wanted yeah he wanted to commit suicide
but then he realized he had to like
finish his book or something
what was that about oh no his
psychoanalyst was like well you've
already paid for your next session so
you
know
that's until next week and he's like oh
fine and then you know the psychonauts
was like well you've already paid for
the next session so
yeah and you know she's like he put in
his inimitable way because he was like
it wasn't just that he didn't want to
lose his money it's just like well i'm
not gonna let you [ __ ] cheat me
bastard you know you don't get a [ __ ]
free session out of me
so i'll be here well let's try to steer
the discussion away from that because
it's not like we're valorizing
it we're commenting on the valorization
of it yeah i know exactly um and i never
know cur i never knew kurt cobain said
that because that's kind of uh
a dark comment that is dark i wonder
that that sounds like something that he
was uh
over indexing or over overrating the uh
consistency of the other in that case oh
you mean
i missed the comfort of being sad quote
no that then
that his fans presumably want him to
you know do oh no that was mark fisher
who wrote that oh that's more
but pills you know i think you actually
like kind of touched on something
important when you were mentioning the
the contrast between like you mentioned
jake paul
and this connects to some of your
earlier videos and commentary about like
social media
you know and i think and i wonder
whether like and then you said
authenticity and i think that's such an
important connective point because
perhaps what's really valorized today
right because there's like a bifurcation
of cultural
currency right like the social media the
image this like happy capitalist life
with like
you know sunshine and poolside drinks
and like you know
attractive people yeah like that's the
that's like the that
that that's like yeah wolf of wall
street right that's like one image and
then
and then there's the reaction to that
image which is the valorization of the
authentic which is actually to be
miserable about like how stupid all the
[ __ ] is yeah but
offering yourselves the one thing you
can't fake that has to be
okay it's like the the one authentic
action that's guaranteed so that's what
you meant by
that's what you meant by authorities i
was actually thinking about it in a
broader in a broader sense that just
well yeah broad now we want to get away
from that yeah i mean so like
i mean when i say broaden it is i mean
like you know people who are
not like not actually like doing like
doing the act
of of offering themselves but you know
just certain artistic types
who are like suffering for their craft
and are miserable with the conditions
there's an
authenticity to them that i think is a
reaction an appropriate reaction to that
like hyper real image
of like social media so to and then but
like but what doesn't exist and i still
will hold by that contention is the
valorization of like that beautiful life
that like you know aristotle talked
about like that's that's nowhere to be
found
i think the reason it's the so we have
to be
careful about valorizing things like
that
because it's like anything else right
you can build up an image of something
it's like
like think about how they recruited
people to go to war for example in like
the first or second world war
like they present it as this like
beautiful thing and this achievement and
you're so manly and self-possessed for
being able to do
it but the problem is it's not really
about the individuals
who join up because they're not the ones
who are going to be there afterwards to
experience those feelings they're going
to be the ones
who don't make it back they're going to
be the ones with some kind of
irreversible condition afterward and
they won't be able to enjoy it
so valorizing it is a very
ethically unsound thing to do i'm
polarizing what
well i'm i'm trying to use going away to
war as a metaphor for suicide but uh
oh okay blew it up yeah i was trying to
get away from that but okay
i think this is an important discussion
though because i mean when we're trying
to ask you know what does it mean to be
happy we really do have to interrogate
why it is that our culture are these
significant elements of our culture seem
fixated on sadness and depression
and even try to valorize it right
because that's a telling indicator that
something's wrong right
i mean if you want a really warped
example of this and i've got much of
them
uh david foster wallace near the end of
his life said that one of the things
that he felt pressured to do
was say that he did heroin um because
even though he was an alcoholic he
understood that some kinds of addiction
were more sexy
as he put it right to the kind of
audience that was going to read a 1500
page book like infinite just right
which is true i should say um but you
know i think that there's deep roots to
this kind of cultural malaise
though uh that go beyond just
postmodernity
uh or late modernity whatever you want
to call it uh the kind of earliest
instance of this kind of fixation on
sadness and its valorization uh was
actually with the
goethe's novel the sorrows of young
verther um
so the source of young virgo is a novel
about
a young guy he doesn't able he's not
able to get the girl that he wants even
though he pursues her for a very long
period of time
uh and then he kills himself at the end
except it's really sad because
he tries to kill himself in this grand
his like heroic way
to kind of show her that he really cares
uh but instead he [ __ ] up and he ends
up dying and suffering for several days
before he passes away and everyone
thinks it's just kind of scary did
anyone hear me
try to get away from this topic did
everyone hear that
i'm gonna get that right and then but
gotcha actually wrote complaining
that he got novel he got fan mail from
people saying
that they were like verita and they were
gonna kill themselves like further and
that this was a heroic thing
and goto was writing back to them being
like no do you not get the [ __ ] point
of this novel which is that this is not
something to do
right it's the sorrows of worth there
for a reason
right and i think that one of the ways
that we need to get away from this
and to move away from the valorization
of sadness
is by recognizing that this is supposed
to serve a therapeutic function
in allowing you to better understand and
cope with your own problems
and then also not and then also overcome
them right i think a lot of people
can use this material as a chance not to
overcome their problems
but just to continuously find their way
back to them
it's no coincidence that at the mention
of authenticity we dive right back to
the romantic era because that's what
yeah
all the ideas about authenticity and
creative genius and the
the individual creating something from
nothing is the sort of
art but that's that's also where the
valorization of what you said sadness
suffering comes from right like
um like you think about byron's sonnets
too they're all about
suffering and tortured people but that's
that's the source of genius and i do
enjoy watching things like i said
earlier adam curtis
and people with a kind of negative
vision of society or something that
makes it think that comes from a place
that's a sort of tortured place or a
depressed place
and then and then that just goes to show
again the sort of weird
intrinsic relationship between suffering
and happiness and our sorts of aesthetic
sensibilities well we got here and uh
i think we'd be remiss if we didn't
mention camus
who said this was the only the only
serious philosophical problem but
i i think i was the one actually who
said this first valorization of uh
sadness and i really honestly don't
think it's a valorization
in the people in most people at least
as far as my empathy goes it's much more
a sense of
catharsis because you know at least
like if loneliness is the worst thing
that you can experience
then knowing that whatever kurt cobain
felt it or david foster
wallace felt it in that recognition
of them there's a recognition that comes
back at you
that you see i'm it's not that they're
valorizing
the act itself i i don't think maybe
some people do that i'm not sure no i i
agree i agree
i i kind of wanted to say that i think
um that's sort of why i was using the
term cultural currency because because i
think there's a catharsis part
but i think there's a step further too
that there's a certain aesthetic or a
cool
aesthetic to people who are perceived to
have
like artistic genius who are also
suffering for their
it's not a valorization but i think
there's there's cultural currency
there's there's a
there's a there's like oh this guy's
authentic like you know i i feel that
too that's the catharsis
part of it too and it's like but they
also you know the gothic
aesthetic is like an example there's
like something that has cultural
currency
in some as being in contrast to like the
sunshine lollipops of like you know wolf
of wall street douchebags right
like the the show friends [ __ ] that
trail
exactly exactly but i think that uh
pills is exactly right and again i think
that
goethe found the right way to deal with
this a long time ago which is
to use these kinds of forms of artistic
expression as a way of helping people
achieve catharsis
uh rather than holding them up as
something to be valorized or commodified
right or to emulate uh you know gyoto
was extraordinarily smart guy einstein
used to say that he was probably the
smartest man in human history
but he wrote a letter to a fan who
really liked garther and he said
look you know i have felt everything
that appears in this book that's why i
wrote it
uh but i am not worth her you know i'm
go to and i went on and let a successful
life and i do this and i have my
interest and i'm
writing my book on color you should do
that too right
find something that brings you a bit of
contentment right uh
and i think there's a lot of practical
wisdom in this right
use this in a wickensteinian sense as a
ladder to help your way through your
depression
um by realizing that other people feel
the same thing
uh and then try to overcome it
right uh don't fall into the kind of
trap of thinking that this is
something that you should want for
yourself or something that you should
stick with
right because it's sexy or in some way
here's redemption through art which is
also a common theme
currently but also in as eric was saying
the romantic age
yeah christian art in general you get to
see jesus suffering and he looks all
bloody
and like the sadder he looks the better
because the more religious people are
going to be after they see
how sad and suffering he is for you yeah
it's so great i love christian art
i should say the culture industry plays
a role in this also i think because um
if you think about a standard biopic
that a lot of people take is
you know the kind of pop expectation for
what great arts should be
a lot of these biopics have the form of
kind of what you know victor and eric
and pills were talking about you know
there's a great genius probably played
by benedict cumberbatch or cumberbatcher
russell crowe
uh he suffers from an awful lot of
problems but that's part and parcel of
why he's a genius right no one can
understand them uh and then at the end
of the movie they go on to win a nobel
prize or venture computer or something
uh even though they've suffered an awful
lot right they have the scene with the
gun next to them
they have the scene with the knife next
to them but they choose to press through
yeah exactly um and i think you know
this has a lot of currency even in
our highly american competitive society
uh where we're told to emulate people
who've accomplished something that's
really great and not take satisfaction
in the small achievements that we've had
in our own life no that's that's like uh
that's a high road to nationalism right
there taking credit for other people's
achievements
yes that's true i i was also i mean
curious uh about
do you guys think um that nowadays
there is a propensity towards like
displacing um on that like the sources
of unhappiness onto like
societal or structural reasons because i
think i see that temptation all the time
and like
the reason i use the sort of
psychoanalytic displacement is because i
just wonder whether
you know thinking about the people who
stormed the capital or whatever who got
angry or whatever
whatever like unhappy people it's like
that seems like an eruption in something
like looking outwards rather than
inwards to like i don't know
really like what like what was your
relationship with your parents like i
don't know i just wonder
if that's worth considering in an age of
of like um
of unhappiness and the discourse about
it always being
you know like the horribleness of if
you're a right-winger right like you
know socialism obama like whatever
like boogeyman and like on the right
it's like capitalism and i'm not saying
these things don't have an effect on our
happiness but i'm just saying i wonder
if there's
a bit of a temptation towards that story
because it allows us to not look inwards
yeah and the reason why i'm unhappy is
because feminism that's why i can't get
laid
er go you know it's a sticky question
because what the when you phrase it like
do you think people project it onto the
structures it's like yes the structures
are making you unhappy it's not that's
not the question the question is which
symbol do you choose to smash because
you're unhappy
exactly right the most visible [ __ ]
thing when something wrong happens you
go to the store and you yell at the
[ __ ] person in there that's what you
do they didn't
have anything to do with the rule that
upset you but you [ __ ] lay into them
because it makes you feel better
so that's more on point we can go to uh
nietzsche and nietzsche's you have like
either an active force or a pat
or a negative force and the negative
force is resentment
and the positive force is creation so at
the end of the day i think if you're
upset at the structures around you which
you should be yeah by the way
according to a lot of the people we've
talked about fischer and and
burnout society and all that then yeah
you have the choice at the end of the
day to
cast that blame on the thing that you
think deserves it
or to try to make your way out of it and
uh
referencing my own work one more time
but christeva comes out exactly on the
same point as nietzsche on this like if
you wanna
if you wanna catharsize cathartise i
don't know what that verb is
if you wanna cathartize yourself out of
it try to make your way
out of it instead of you know uh
negating
yeah i want to say i completely agree
with what eric said and
i think that this is where it gets
really tricky right because
on the one hand you know it can be very
tempting to de-politicize the sources of
our unhappiness which is what a lot of
reactionaries do
right which is to say don't project
blame on to
contemporary institutions for what's
going on with your life or why you
aren't happy
look inward right uh pick yourself up
and change your life you can do it right
uh and i think that's a really dangerous
thing to say
uh and it's also wrong right a lot of
times the reasons people are unhappy
does have its root in unjust social
structures right
uh where i do think that you know it
becomes problematic though is
what people choose to locate as the
source
for their unhappiness right uh if
they're choosing to locate the source of
their unhappiness and things that
genuinely are unjust and problematic uh
that's fine you know those energies are
channeled in the right place and i think
everything from like the civil rights
movement um through to you know the ab
movement to end apartheid has its root
in this kind of sentiment right
if they're choosing to locate the roots
of their own happiness and something
like anti-semitism
or racism uh or feminism that's much
more problematic
immigrants and colleges god this is like
the second time in this podcast where i
feel like something i've said has been
made to sound reactionary no no i don't
think you feel that way i'm just saying
that i think
eric is right that it's it's problematic
to sit there
and just say the solution to your
problem is i agree i agree but like but
like
let me let me try to hedge a little bit
because i think really what i mean he's
just riffing and
trying no no no no no no no no no no but
i agree i mean i think it's an important
point but but i also
you know i mean we're all all four of us
here are sympathetic to psychoanalytic
theory and i just
and i wonder don't don't we think like
as all of us being sympathetic that like
we all
must be somewhat convinced that like our
relationship growing up has a huge
impact on our on our on our psyche later
on oh yeah like like like so like
i'm not saying that it's our fault but
i'm just saying like if we start to just
blame everything
on uh on like on external forces like as
unjust
i mean i think we should condemn
external forces because they're unjust
not because they're making me
uh like psychologically unhappy just
because they're an unjust arrangement
based on
whatever judgment we use but you know i
think there's like
what you know there's if we if we're
sympathetic to psychoanalytic theory i
mean surely
you know there's there's reason to think
about uh you know our relationship with
our parents and
all these things that happened before
and i think it can be plausibly
convenient
to to not want to look at that and just
be like well let's look at capitalism
that's why i'm so unhappy
victor of course i agree with you if
we're saying psychoanalysis
in that frame it never ends with your
relationship with your parents that's
true that's where it
starts that's where you develop the
patterns that's why you signify certain
things as
as above others or lower than others or
more consistently than others or not
but re-signifying in that case
like whatever if you want to translate
it into weird reactionary politics
that's mostly a choice that can be
changed that's a it's a
it's following a pattern but the pattern
is signifying
in a way that can be changed not a way
that's immutable
yeah right just i jump to the the other
side
immediately too fast because you're
right yeah there's there's an amazing
amount of insight to be added like
looking to the unconscious
for reasons why unhappiness
and all these other sorts of sorts of
neurotic things are going on
but also the only reason is i just don't
want to give in
also to the opposite which is
psychologizing pathologizing
unhappiness too quickly as well because
that's
again sorry i'm fresh off of century of
the self so i have all these problems
with it but like despite the insight
psychoanalysis tends to say you know if
you're
unhappy with your boss if you're unhappy
with capitalism if something's pissing
you off about the way that person
treated you at the store what it really
has to do with is your
life growing up you don't hate
capitalism you hate your father
and it tries to always locate and
psychologize like i said these
problems within that when you say mummy
daddy me triangle
it tries to triangulate all your
problems
and pathologize them and make it seem
like it's a result of your
unique setup of drives and
compartments of the psyche but it's not
always the
case and i think you know mid-century
and later psychoanalysis start to think
this way is
marcus saying you know it's not
everything can't be related back to that
childhood experience that structures
maybe the rest of your life but it
doesn't
determine it such that all
forms of discontent can just be related
back to it exactly i want to start off
with
and we finish on anti-oedipus are almost
finished
sorry matt no i did want to say that uh
i feel really resentful that victor was
saying that i can't blame myself for all
my problems as a
reformed roman catholic not only am i
going to blame myself for my problems
i feel like i should be blaming myself
for your problems and eric's problems
and i'll [ __ ] bear them all
like that cross that i was told
i just want to say i think that from is
really right about this right and
he has problems there's serious problems
with this site in a second why not i
take but i usually use him and jesus
models for
what a kind of emancipatory and
political psychoanalysis can be right
because
one of the things that he says is like
there's no doubt that the roots of a
huge amount of our traumas
lie in childhood right either we have
bad parents
uh and we long for a sense of order uh
that
you know could have been provided if we
actually had good ones uh or we have
parents that are too stern in which case
that we grow up with this
sense that we're never good enough uh
that everything is gonna be inadequate
and so on and so forth right
but he says this doesn't really become
problematic until we become adults and
we start to invest ourselves in
political projects
that are designed to modify these
feelings right
uh and one of the things that he points
out about uh fascists is
a lot of them grew up with this deep
anxiety that the world is disordered
right and that the reason it's
disordered is because
people just aren't strong enough to
impose order on it
and so what's needed is precisely a
paternal father figure who's going to
come in
and set things right by taking away all
the dangerous forms of freedom and
individuality that they see in their
society
and of course that's one of the
psychoanalytic appeals uh sorry
technology explanations
for the appeal of fascism right and i
think that's where you make the
connection right you know yes you know
these might be problems in youth and
maybe we can look it back there
but it definitely has bearing later on
when we're trying to see how about why
people
invest themselves on certain kinds of
political projects uh and what we want
to do is
direct them uh if they do have these
kinds of problems
towards healthier uh kinds of political
resolutions to their difficulties
right yeah that's good i mean i think i
think ultimately what we've come to is
uh
you know we have to hold uh like two
truths
at the same time partially right about
um look at the causes of various things
or multiple truths which should be
our job as academic thinkers true two
truths one cup right
[Laughter]
well does everybody feel uh pretty again
what's
the verb catharsized
i just want to clarify that you
shouldn't go yell
at anyone working in a grocery store
or anything i think everyone got that
man
eric is telling you that if you have a
problem just take it out on the person
who's one rung below the social
hierarchy than you
i just wanted to [ __ ] catcher do not
yell
at them do not storm the capitol
also don't kill yourself please not
constructive ways of dealing with your
problems
anyway speaking of others not making me
happy uh you guys want to play some
axis and allies right now yes yes
yes of course i want to play i can't
wait i called germany so we're
cathartized with our
catheters catheterized everybody good
all right open your dick i'll see you
guys next week
see ya hey eric if you're if you're free
you should come talk to me about adam
curtis on my stream on friday
oh yeah all right i'm down